- Every night in this
country around three a.m.
women find themselves in
bedrooms after one-night stands
completely dehydrated.
Hyrdration.
Unsure of whether
you have a Britta,
they wonder how long it
will take for you to notice.
- [Nikki] Get her
a glass of water.
- So until then they stare
at that Dos Equis poster
deep into the eyes of
the Most Interesting
Man In the World.
Stay thirsty.
They will.
Get her a glass of water.
They leave your apartment
feeling parched and weak
desperately searching for a 7-11
or hoping to catch one
of those Uber drivers
that has those tiny bottles
of water in the back seat.
- [Nikki] Massoud gets
five stars, five stars.
[All] Get her a glass of water.
- [Nikki] You bought
her well vodka.
- Two for one.
Get her a glass of water.
[All] Get her a glass of water.
Get her a glass.
Not one of those
plastic ones you have
from your college pizza place
that you use as an ashtray.
A glass is made of glass.
You refer to her boobs
as 'dem titties',
'dem sweet fat natties'.
- [Nikki] Show some respect.
- [All] Get her
a glass of water.
Seriously, she just fucked you.
Like, get her a glass of water.
Is that so much to ask?
Like, does this really
need this whole thing?
And how come you don't
have toilet paper?
I had to use the cardboard roll.
It's bullshit, okay?
Bullshit.
It's bullshit.
Or just go get yourself
some water, girls.
You deserve it.
Don't even ask, lean in.
Whatever.
- [Nikki] Get her a
glass of fucking water.